uh i'm super excited to make this
uh to talk about
this tonight i hope you guys will enjoy
the class i'm planning to
discuss um a game that basically
kind of helped jane pognachi qualify
um to the candidates tournament
and this is a game that he played
against boris gilfund
in jerusalem in 2019
that was uh the won the last grand prix
tournaments if you guys remember for the
candidates there were
various ways that players could qualify
and so um i decided
to okay after having talked
to um
uh grandmaster el shan uh moradia body
uh he has suggested this and i was like
oh yeah that's a great idea thank you so
much
uh because i wanted something you know
about
nepo since you know now all the talk is
about him he is the
the challenger to magnus carlsen we're
going to see a world championship
match in december in dubai so i think
everyone is looking forward to that
and since that's what's happening i
thought it would be nice to kind of
talk a little bit about him and you know
it's never
and not always wins are the ones that
uh make a player special right but you
sometimes have to see the struggle and
how they come back from difficult
situations and things like that and of
course he has
had a lot of amazing games throughout
his chess career but i think
um you know it's kind of nice to see how
he came
to to be where he is today and um
yeah so once again
this is a game from the grand prix in
jerusalem which took place
in december 2019 and it was a 16 player
knockout tournament
in the first round he was spared against
boris gilfond and things could have gone
anyway since this was a knockout
tournament eventually he did win the
match 3-1 but
um first two games were a draw so
and this is game two from their match
um let us get started so
and of course if you have any uh
questions or anything i'll be very happy
to answer them
all right so they played
this is played knight f3 zukertord
technically right knight f3 first move
but
it transposed to an english c5 c4 knight
c6
d4 all right
there are many lines that white can play
in this position of course if they want
to continue with the english they would
have to play with g3 knight c3
is an option you can also try to play it
but linux system
there's so many lines that white can
choose but in this game board scale fund
went for d4
big steak so we basically have
um sicilian um
idea so so white can try to play e4
later
knight f6 now in this position d5
is another you know typical idea for
black
and for example if you take in c6
one takes c6 uh c takes e5
c takes d5 knight c3 knight f6
black can try to hold on to the central
pawn
and just play you know play here with
the central pawn
but um
this is something that kasparov has
played himself with the white pieces
and okay it's it's
a playable line i would say like a
possibility here
going back
knight d4 uh d5
um some interesting alternative for
white after this d5 is not necessarily
knight x
c6 but they can also play like queen a4
this is kind of an interesting approach
the idea being that they are trying to
put pressure here so you cannot really
take
in c4 because knight takes
and um after pawn takes black does have
some messed up
pawns we are not going to be in a rush
to capture either one of them
and um i think white could continue
maybe
[Music]
bishop d2 to have ideas in bishop a5
knight c3
and these pawns eventually will fall
this e pawn will
be pushed maybe or white can either
develop like this or push the e pawn
taking c4 and have a good position
welcome everyone thank you so much for
joining
um
but here after queen b6 there's also
this line and this is usually quite
typical
for white to play in english lines after
playing d4
and the trades happen uh this move often
happens tonight comes to b5 with ideas
of knight c7 bishop f4
and so on but then we can go
d4 and here c5
this is a potential line
that could happen but anyways this is a
completely different i would say it's a
completely different
story than what happened in the game
nepo went for knight f6
knight c3 uh which is a pretty natural
um development for white
knight c3 also controls the e4 square
and could support any four pawn push for
white e6
now uh technically with black in this
position if you want to
transpose to other types of sicilians
like the dragon
you could play g6 and try to go into a
mario team
but i think at the higher level maruti
is not really that popular
and for example if you go here
black has not only played d6 but black
has also taken there
and then played d6 and then bishop g7
castle and there are
so many players that black can play
against the maruti and i
i really personally i haven't seen it
much being played at the higher level
but of course
at the lower level this is this is
always an option and
if you're a dragon player you would have
to learn how to play
uh against amerity of course
but in the game nepo decided instead of
g6 to play
e6 um
and there are many options in this
position because after e6 what is black
trying to do
um he's weakening temporary the d6
square and leaving the d7 pawn
backwards technically but he's preparing
to play some d5
right that is some idea that he's
preparing to do
and um
white has again a few options if they
want to stop
uh they cannot really stop d5 because a
move like
e4 here would allow some development
moves like bishop c5
and then your knight would have to go
back because here
your lock will be six idea putting
additional pressure so usually after
bishop c5
white could return the knight
and then there's castle and i think
black has a pretty decent position
yeah yeah e6 is a very typical cnn
um so so most people here would not play
uh
e4 it's more like other options so
because they're also thinking that black
would want to play bishop b4 so a3 is
another option
and then white could try to consider
getting some space on the queen side for
example
but i think black and equalize kind of
easily they just go bishop e7
and then the castle
queen a5 of course and d5 will be a move
that they want to prepare to play
obviously because they don't want to let
white have too much control over the
center but they first would castle
castling is very important in
a game so a3 wouldn't really be
that big of a deal i would say um e3 is
an option
i've seen many people trying to do this
to support
i mean to strengthen their knight in d4
in case you're considering to trade to
recapture with the pawn of course
um but but black can basically do the
same thing and then they can castle
and d5 will be always an option that
they may want to do but they could also
stick to d6
just for the development of this bishop
it would be important for them to do
something
b6 bishop b7 uh rook c8 and then at some
point they would have to play d5 because
you cannot just stay
so restricted you have to eventually
attack the center
so as you can see like there are quite
some options here for white to be
to be played but in the game gelfand
chose g3 which actually i like very much
um bobby fischer was a player who would
often
you know choose in sicilian i know this
is not a sicilian
really it's an english because there's
no there's no e4 being played yet but
bobby fischer is the one who would often
like this kind of
you know um idea with g3 bishop g2
anyways lots of players like that move
um but it's uh
it's it's definitely a nice development
and of course if you're going to play g3
you will try not to push the e
pawn too soon because you definitely
want the bishop to be opened
and with the bishop you cannot control
both diagonals that's something very
important to keep in mind
queen b6 this is like a very typical
move for black here uh of course you can
still play bishop b4 if you want to but
the point is that we are not worried if
you are thinking to play bishop before
just to ping that knight that's fine you
can castle here but if you're thinking
to do it to to to mess up white spawns
actually it's not going to be so easy
for black to attack them
and if you're not careful they could
play some c5 and then whenever you push
d6 or b6 to develop your bishop if you
manage to do so
white will be able to to trade their
double pawn
and anyways it will be very tough for
you given the pressure here and if you
take you're actually going to help them
so this kind of idea is not so great uh
just remember if you're playing this
with black
you're not playing bishop b4 to
necessarily take the knight but more
like pinit
and then support d5
queen b6 was played and as i said this
is like pretty typical
for these types of positions lots of
sicilians and english openings to
end up like that um
might be
uh knight d to b5 as i was telling you
previously
is another option and
trying to take control over the e6
the d6 square now
d5 is not really an option for black in
this position
because we get to take and you have to
go bishop c5 because you cannot
recapture your
you're staying on a knight c7 eventually
so if you go bishop c5
um e3 may need to be played by white
i think but uh white could also just
give up the f2 pawn because then your
bishop will be
stuck there you know like uh bishop g2
maybe you can take and then king f1 and
then you'll have to go back
and white should be able to hide with
their team
eventually black thing is in the center
too this is a little bit
complicated i'm not going to go that
much into it it requires quite some
analysis
but uh knight d5 i believe is is
something that that makes a
little bit more sense and now white can
go bishop g2
and uh say you go a6 to chase the the
knight away first
um and here
tricky idea queen e4
if you go to b8
we can go back there are a lot of lines
here
that um and a lot of games that are
played if someone
is interested in playing this you
definitely need to spend a little bit of
time researching it
but this is certainly an option for
white
knight b3 was however played in the game
by yelpfund a very typical
type of retreat move uh also controlling
the c5 square which is nice because then
you know black will not be able to put
pressure on f2
still 95 because as you're choosing to
play g3 bishop g2
that pawn remains weak so black is
trying to take
control over it and it's trying to make
you move this knight once again but
obviously nobody's gonna go knight d2
right
so here white supposedly has to make
this move that's
um i don't want to say anti-positional
but in a way it is anti-positional
because
you cannot usually push both g
the g and e pawns in the english at
least in my opinion you cannot do that
in general um but he kind of has to
because he doesn't have another way to
defend
and e4 is the move with which he does
that because
he's opening up the bishop to protect
and now he's taking control over the
center
he's also controlling the d5 square
because black
you know with the queen here and b6 it's
not going to be easy for black to
develop and you will see
he had a really tough position he was
able to escape this
and you know sometimes you need a little
bit of luck you cannot just be a strong
player
and play play well like we all make
mistakes at some point and need a little
bit of luck and i think he's
had plenty of luck in this game
picture b4 uh
and now queen two
c5 is an alternative for um
for white definitely requires
uh some thought but um and
after queen c6 you probably have to play
f3
bishop g2 is an option too but um it it
gets a little bit messy
so f3 and then b6 bishop f4 and um
the complicated position but in the game
guilford shows queen e2 which i like a
little bit because
the queen does require development
you're still controlling
every single square not leaving anything
behind or defending your two pawns
and then he's uh he's proceeding with
he's just proceeding with the
development now d5 is also not an option
because
something else that the queen does there
is staying on the same
uh file is the king so this
push is going to be very difficult not
only the king is there but also this
knight in e5 so
if you would ever play d5 will take and
this knight would be hanging
kind of obvious but i thought i'd
explain it just in case
[ __ ] of detail
longer time ago it seems like f4 was
more of a popular move but these days
bishop d2 is more of a of an option and
here
nepo made a mistake uh some
grandma you know different people have
analyzed this game
and have suggested that bishop d7 was a
mistake
um castle would have been
a nice alternative because you
definitely need to proceed with your
development
and after long castle which seems to be
you know the way
most players proceed in this line
um a5
and now we have opposite side castling
so white is going to try to attack
black on the king side the white is
getting ready
uh white will have to be ready also for
black's attack
on the queen side with the king being a
little bit weak
and the knights here which will help
a5a4 be coming into a tempo
and it it gets to be a really complex
um complex and complicated position
because after f4 there's a4 and and
really lots of analysis i can tell you
so like for example here
then takes takes and
good move for white in these types of
positions keep in mind you do not want
to open up files
you try to keep the position as close as
possible
and you need to make sure there are no
sacrifices that would lead to your king
being weak but if you don't see anything
like that
try to pass by with your pawns keep the
position close so that the opponent
doesn't have the opportunity
to take control and over open files and
attack your king
you always want to keep it as close as
possible
but anyways this would be a completely
different game completely
so many different lines but um bishop d7
is actually what was played in the game
and as i said many grand masters did
suggest that would be a
that was a mistake a5 can also be played
first
um and um could transpose after
after a long castle if white if black
castles
but black would also try a4 and knight
a1 in that case because we don't have
the opportunity to attack the knight
black would actually open up the
position and then castle
and then knight c2 and again like some
complicated position with the rice
but in the game
um
b57 was played and from here on gelfont
really gets to take over
the position and get um
[Music]
a really good position that could have
had very annoying
uh you know consequences for jan
or nepo f4
that was a type of move that you would
expect white to play anyways because
this knight is you know definitely a
target
being there in the center uh and it has
to just
go back if you go back to c6 there's e5
here just opening up the position
so he went to g6 keeping the king
supposedly safe but anyways
e5 was played
now the white bishop d7 was a mistake
for those of you who played the sicilian
you have to remember this i'm personally
not a sicilian player
so i know this from when i played a
little bit the sicilian and what i've
seen
the d7 square usually needs to be free
so that this knight could retreat there
in a lot of situations especially if
there are options for
white to push g4 g5 or e5
usually this knight goes this is a path
that it takes it's a very typical knight
d7
sorry knight d7 knight c5
this is a typical path that black takes
with the knight in many many seasons
okay sometimes you know you can go in in
d5 but
this morning doesn't you don't really
see that often uh sometimes you go to
each part but really like most of the
time that is the path and if you don't
have that path freed
then um you're it's a problem
it you're having a problem and this is
basically what
um what black has in this position
he has a small problem here with the
knight
um
pawn takes it's kind of necessary uh an
idea like bishop c6 would be
something you could consider because
you're supposedly moving the bishop
out with temple and then freeing that
square for your knight to go
next but unfortunately this doesn't seem
to work because white can just take the
knight
you take the rook then you take here you
have to go rg8 so so far
so good everything is pretty forcing and
now white can castle
and the point is that if you take for
example in g7
and say you know what i have plenty of
material what are you talking about well
your king is not really so safe here in
the center
and white can make a lot of moves with
temple that will
annoy very much working in the center
like for example bishop e3 knight b5
um and um
maybe bishop h3 as well and white has
plenty of compensation for this exchange
that they are giving up
so that is not necessarily
something you can do so jan decided to
take there
you have to take back and then go back
knight g8
once again if he's going bishop c6 um
something annoying would happen but not
capture but c5 here
the queen has to go back and now take so
that move was important because it was
forcing the queen to go back
and now if you choose to take there now
there's this
check very annoying check bishop
queen takes b4 and white will have two
pieces for the rook plus
some more pawns are hanging the king is
not safe this wouldn't be a very
pleasant position to play
uh in case knight takes e5 there could
be an option too
you can think i'm just gonna sacrifice
and have some ideas
here to win the rook there's still the
c5
very annoying move and the point is you
don't really have a good
placement for the queen if you go back
here
um or i can just move the rook because
you don't have control over the square
anymore
and we've got an extra piece
so um if you capture
thinking that if they take then you get
to take the rook and they're doing
at least decent you have two pawns
and they look for two pieces but uh
maybe maybe that's not necessarily
you know something to be super worried
about because i think bishop b5 is also
an option
but even this i mean even this could be
fine i i gotta tell you because
then bishop e3 and uh
bishop b5 and long castle and white will
be having a very good position
so here i'm back and now if you sit and
you look at this position you realize
that
okay the opening stage is getting close
to being
over we are almost 14 and
um it's um
it's not very pleasant for black yes
definitely both kings are in the center
but for white white is one move away
from castling they can cast alongside
whenever they feel like it but um but
for black it's not that easy
to come up with something you know so
c5 very nice idea
queen had to go back the point is i
think it's pretty clear that drop takes
doesn't quite um doesn't quite help
black because white can simply take and
then go 94
followed by knight d6 and this is often
what happens when you
lose your dark square bishop in a
sicilian style position
after you push the e6 and you you have a
hole in d6
this is always an idea that can happen
and it's certainly in white's favor
so after c5 piano went back you probably
thought okay i can survive this but no
the king is in the center
and look at how nicely gailfund is
taking control of this night here
i i could have put the position from
my's perspective i don't know i choose
to show you from black's perspective i
guess because
uh we're trying to to kind of show how
jan
survived and um got to you know
win this match and then later on win the
rest of his matches and qualify for the
candidates
so 94 and sometimes when you you your
luck is on your side it's on your side
and you get to
uh to to do really well and get
to the result that you want or you need
so bishop takes d2 is more or less
forcing now
a5 wouldn't work they would just take
here 96 and
this king would not survive so
now you probably realize that grabbing
this pawn would not really help him
for example after queen takes
maybe knight c4 uh bishop h3
knight d6 or this one or this one they
could see maybe this one and then the
other one could also go to g5
white has a very very nice attack
the extra pawn is not even visible and
black's king is in the center so it's
not really
a very safe position but he could have
tried but um
he decided to focus on development and
this was definitely a good choice
96 chuck and now he chose to move the
king
now you have two options you can keep
the king in e7 or in f8 he did go to f8
i feel like e7 would have made a little
bit more
sense but it's still not so easy because
the idea would be
you know you're trying to get this
bishop here get the rook out and
bring in the king king of faking g8 and
maybe hide like that but he decided to
go king c8
and now white play b4
defending his his c5 pawn of course
it is lagging i'm not sure if it is
lagging maybe maybe it is lagging i
apologize if that is the case
i'm hoping not there isn't too much lag
okay so maybe there there could be
something in my internet seems to be
working well
now you play bishop c6
and now
um bishop g2
he is giving up the e5 pawn and it was
really really interesting it was really
really interesting
galvan's choice to give up the e5 pawn
uh
you could try with white rook g1 but i
think he just wanted to make things a
little bit faster he wanted to finish
his development and this is what i like
from this game
the way white plays to try to
to take control over not take control
but just like make things faster
sometimes you have to give up material
in order to make things you know go a
little bit faster
temple making most of temple takes takes
and now yan took the pawn what to do i
mean it's not so easy for black to get
a safety place for this king if you play
a move like knight f5
i think i can even castle here and just
you know just keep putting pressure on
the file because you cannot support your
knight there it's gonna be chased away
very fast and there's not so much that
you can do about it
so i think grabbing an e5 was definitely
like one of the best choices he could do
but
white still castled and i like this very
much because as i said he's putting a
lot of pressure on black's king and it's
not so easy
for them to escape f6
is very hard to make i think the engine
was suggesting
f6 in this position but for a human to
play f6 here
it's just it just doesn't feel right
because you you want the king you want
it gone and you want the rook to come
in you you don't really want to play f6
it's just
feels like there could be some night
coming to e4 potential sacrifices um not
really
not really something that that you would
consider doing so
knight f5 and now
um bringing another piece to the attack
this knight was not saying so well this
rook will have to be brought into play
as well but
this night being brought is good because
in case you know a trade would happen
the other night could come into play um
grabbing here was a choice as well he
could try to get his pawn back
and then continue the attack but i think
it could give
black some opportunities of g6 king g7
and trying to consolidate
a tiny little bit the position and so i
think he wanted to avoid that so he won
84.
now in this position jan decided
to try to get some counterplay since he
wasn't sure probably how to bring his
king to safety and now
you know after 94 grabbing an f5 starts
becoming an annoying idea
he thought he would try to move the play
on the other side of the board and this
is like a typical idea you're taught
that someone could do moving you know
from from
from um the play from your king
to the other side of the board so he
went a5
knight takes a five
pawn takes f5 and here
uh knight to d6 this was
this was knight e3 what
ah you're saying no this move
unfortunately would not work for black
but thanks for pointing it out
indeed uh this move would not work
because um
there's queen b2 very strong move that
attacks the knight
and then if you get to take the rook
this will recapture this knight is being
attacked
and you don't quite have a good
placement for it because wherever you
move it
there'll be an ig5 or rook takes f7
simply rotates f7
and you kind of have to sacrifice and
then night
night here uh and uh and
some of these pawns will start falling
and blacks
rooks are not coordinated the queen and
the knight will be much stronger than
the black strokes they are not
coordinated and
and um and white will have an amazing
position so 93 is nice but unfortunately
this idea uh does not work thanks for
pointing that out
i could explain uh queen b2 is also a
nice idea that could be played
the end game is not good for black only
if you would have managed to get the
rooks activated but because of the check
the king would have to go on the back
rank and it would be
a much much better position for the
queen
the rooks don't get to be
activated so here he went for
a5
knight xf5 uh as i said this queen b2 is
a really nice idea
as well um and then some knight g5s
maybe some g4 depends what you're doing
here this could have been nice for white
but knight xf5
was uh galvan's choice which keeps him
in a very strong position he does not
recapture here
because now there's g6 and it's a
similar idea as i said previously the
king can hide and
and black may be able to escape this
this attack but knight d6 um
g6 of course and the point is that even
if
we give up a pawn here
um now after g6 the diagonal will be
weak
the square still remains weak and black
has to make
uh black will will have to stay
to somehow find some way to save himself
this is a very strong move you kind of
have to play f6 there was no
there's no easy way to to defend if you
play here for example there's b5
and the knight doesn't have a good
square to go like if you go here
i think you end up losing something on
the
maybe not exactly but you can certainly
bring in the rook
queen here and try to mate
there's no easy defense for black even
uncoordinated pieces
so that's the reason why after queen d5
he played with v8
sorry he played f6 first i'm sorry
f6 first and after b5 he played r8
um white is trying to get ready to
eventually push c6 and create their past
pawn
black doesn't seem to be having fun
black is having a very tough position
his king didn't reach safety yet and
there could always be some sacrifices in
f5
white's moves are all coming in with
temple he played with b8 here but
for example if you're thinking why
didn't he go there well he would lose
this pawn
and this would be kind of kind of
annoying once that pawn gets to be
pushed
that one is weak the default will
probably be taken by
by white it's it's not so easy it's not
so easy
so b5 ruby
and
um look a to e1
would have been probably more like a
natural way of why to bring in a new
piece to the attack
and then having the sacrifice here is
very difficult
to meet by by blacks pieces there's no
way to stop that sacrifice
from happening if rook takes e5 pawn
takes queen takes e5
um there there's some annoying checks
there's g4 coming in another coming in
we're sacrificing the exchange temporary
but
really black does not get to bring this
game to safety it would have been really
really tough instead galvan play b6
which gives gives black some opportunity
of defense queen to d7
correct uh correct approach
queen e7 would lead to rookie one
and uh followed by g4
and white is trying to take advantage of
these two pieces being
completely pinned and potential
sacrifices and again as i said you have
to think on a passive now this is weak
the rook has to stay
there's no way for this other rook to
come in out
it's really tough but you play queen d7
and now with black you need to
come up with some way again as i said
for a king to
to to go to safety if you do go there
it's not going to be safe
because after the um exchange sacrifice
you cannot go there
there will be rook f4 look h4 and it's
something they cannot stop
um if you go to g8 you're going to be
stuck maybe even knight takes f5 could
work here
because that rook is hanging so you
cannot really stay too safe
in this position but nepo came up with
this interesting idea
of hiding with the king to h6 so he's
starting with h4 yet but also he has an
idea
of getting this rook into play like this
and maybe
some h4 at some point too why not
um white in this position must
act immediately must come up with some
way
to to improve otherwise really
if they don't act immediately black will
bring the rook to e7
protect the knight get the king to g7
and he will be totally fine he has to
escape from this
difficult situation but um
white went for it and i love it i love
this move i think it's really nice rook
takes e5 you know what
i'm sacrificing i'm going all-in like
if you guys don't know boris gelfand you
should definitely check out his games
he also has three books that were
published really really nice books
i only had the chance to look through
the first one i definitely need to check
the other two
um but um definitely a great
player and you know how they say that as
you
get to be older you're not going to be
playing that much dynamic chess not
sacrificing nothing who says that
that's a lie guys that that's a lie you
know what don't
ever let anyone tell you you can't do
something because you are
a different age or you are i don't know
higher in age or you are
i don't know you have something that
no nothing there's nothing that you
cannot do
whatever it is you can do it okay just
keep that in mind
how did why not we're gonna figure out
we're gonna figure out what happened
so he can play tactical chess why not
this is gorgeous
pawn takes queen takes i hear king g8
only move
really because if you go to page seven
um
there is uh another sacrifice coming in
right uh maybe this is not a real
sacrifice because now
he had a positional book exactly but
guess what
just because he's writing positional
books doesn't mean he cannot play
attacking chess
right um so anyways this is this would
have been a killer so that's why in this
position blacks only move
after which she doesn't lose it is king
g8 because you need to escape from those
it's really not safe um
and now um it's going to be tough for
white
i think um they they might have gone
into time travel here do not remember
the circumstances
of this game but uh but guilford went
for
this interesting move knight to e4
um queen f6 would have been an
alternative that makes a lot of sense to
try to put pressure on g6
uh but now king h7 because obviously you
cannot protect like think that oh i'm
gonna trade the queens and i'm going to
be really fine no you're not going to be
really fine because after this and if
you're trying to sacrifice
you're not getting much if queen takes
queen g6
and i can you know cover all the checks
with the queen and if you
uh but uh but but the rook takes and
then
it's kind of game over because you know
that is impossible to stop or or lucas
down is going to be made
so quick g7 would not work here
um so king h7
and now there's this interesting idea
because sacrificing here does not seem
to help white very much you don't want
to trade queens and if you grab
like if you take here
something like this could happen i think
you have perpetual check
or queen d1 queen g4 or something but
also
after knight takes f5 since there's no
real threat
black can also go look at faint and you
might end up losing like big time so
that's why this would not be a good
choice for white
but they have this other idea trying to
combine the attack on the king side
with this other side of the board and
try to open up a new front
that's a typical you know attacking idea
so c6 you take back
and then maybe he can try to to to
to play this and you can ask me where
why don't you just play there
immediately well because we can play
luke
rookie just sacrificing the exchange
back and um
and probably black and hold on to this
position
but why can't he do the same thing here
you're asking he can
rookie take stakes
but the point is that you're trying to
play into this end game where you have a
queen end game
with that b-pawn past and you can try to
find a way to avoid checks by black
and try to support your b-pawn it may
not be easy but this is something you
can try to do
and i think you probably would have
given girlfriend a little bit more
chances
instead he went for 94
rook f8 knight f6 check
forcing the rook uh exchange sacrifice
back queen takes
and now king h7 this position
no it's not really objectively a draw
white is much better throughout
the entire game um but yeah he did make
he didn't make a few inaccuracies as you
um let's let's keep going
k7 and now uh rookie one
again this idea would have been really
interesting because you have to take
with the pawn obviously queen takes
leads to takes x
and not b7 sorry king f2
and this is really tough you have to go
there
oops sorry here
but black has some weaknesses that for
example if you bring in the king
and you cannot really stop
no white spawns are more advanced
specifically this b pawn is
is a past pawn and it's not so easy to
stop
so this would have been a a nice idea
but
you can take with the pawn still rookie
one
and kind of transpose to the other line
that we saw previously tried to trade
the rooks and get into this
queen end game but white should still be
better because their pawn is way more
advanced
than black spawn but he played rookie
one directly he didn't play the
c6 and what's the difference
yeah the b pawn is really really strong
the difference is that here in this
position after rook takes
they agreed on the draw because they
probably thought after queen takes
queen c3
um it's not going to be easy for white
to kind of have a way to
improve because there's always queen
here controlling
c6 if you play c6 i think we even have
check and
uh and maybe perpetual depending on
where you move the king
so and this is where they agreed on a
draw after rookie 8 rook 68
the players agreed on a draw but think
about how
difficult this must have been for yan
going back to see exactly like what
happened in the game right because when
you see the game the first time you may
not realize
how strong of an attack white had but
think about
how hard it must have been to play with
that king in the center
all that time right must have been
really tough
because you always had to look for ways
not to
allow sacrifices how to get your rooks
out of it
it was really a tough game i i i don't
know if i could play
such a game so let's go back again to
see the position from
somewhere around here right what
happened exactly in the game
and where could white have gone that
wrong there were
certainly some sacrifices that i
suggested
but but let's see again so
look at that so he gave up that pawn
jack so he uh girlfriend kept
kept nepo's king in the center right
that was a big thing that they did
then before bishop c6 right and here
instead of
trying to to keep the material balanced
like going through g1 he decided to give
up a pawn and this is a really nice
positional pawn sacrifice that gelfand
did this is really nice right so he went
bishop g2 aligning the trays of the
bishops
giving up that pawn and then keeping
black skiing in the center for a really
long time and
those files got open so it worked out
really well he castled
he played knight e4 and then nepo went
for this a5 line if you guys remember
trading there was a good idea as well
and he played knight here he did not
rush because he probably thought again
as we as we discussed either atx before
or just g6 directly
and maybe
or just the 8xb4 first
using them back playing king 27 and
covering themselves
and i think around here after b5
or before b5 white could have
could have had this option of bringing
more pieces i think he might have rushed
a little bit
there but the b4 does make a lot of
sense and it seems nice but this is an
option too to try to sacrifice a little
bit earlier than in the game
he might have thought this could not
work but he also has this way of opening
up the
the position
but anyways i think the biggest chance
that white
missed was over here
after the sacrifice 94
like really nice move
although a queen f6 right you guys
remember like when you have six nine i
think that could have
given white some um
some nice position
if you guys remember our discussions
here
so 94 and
that c3 c6 move could have
changed a little bit the game he had to
take with the pawn if you guys remember
and then rookie one
it is very difficult it is very
difficult to defend here
like this
it would have been in my opinion very
difficult to defend
but he did a really good job with the
defense i mean we got to give him that
and with white with the engine if you
have the engine on and you're looking at
this and that and the other one yeah you
have
great ways of um
of saving yourself but
over the board it must have been really
hard i mean imagine how long black
stayed with his king in the center
and he only had move around 30 he was
able 33
actually he was able to bring the king
to h7 and get the rook into play
just took a little bit long so that was
the
queen f6 move idea over here he had it
queen f6 first
a little bit later that c6 push and even
a little bit earlier
maybe uh when he played
instead of this b6 this was another like
this was that other moment where
he probably rushed pushing b5 was
helpful
because it didn't really help black
it didn't let black you know trade some
pawns create some ideas for themselves
so this was nice but that b6
in king and pawn and games that move is
super strong because then
you have the c6 pawn push and you're
creating your past pawn it goes
really really well but um
but but here b6
didn't turn out so good because it
wasn't a king of pawn and game they
didn't really
reach a king component game and that c6
move
would not really lead to a complete win
or something like that you know
so this after b5 b6 was definitely
so bringing in the rook to the attack
would have helped him
much more here i think this was the
moment where he could have had
potentially uh some very annoying ideas
and you have to found
h5 or b6 and it's it's not so easy
really um
but um but this is how
how jan got got lucky in a way he got
his draw
and then he ended up winning the rapids
or blizz whatever it was i think it was
rapid
and qualified so pretty nice
i hope you guys enjoyed this game that
is all
i had uh for this uh
this video do you guys have any
questions i'd be happy to answer any
questions for the next few minutes if
you guys have any
questions about the game about nipple
looks like nobody has questions
i do appreciate you guys joining in i
really hope once again that you enjoyed
this video in the game uh
i will be making a short break taking a
short break
and coming back up with another
live stream on my favorite games
on my favorite games of the week
i actually have one game
one game of the week we'll see if you
guys like it
and
a5 was not the correct move for black
when he played a5
no not really not the best i think
uh instead of that he probably should
have gone um
this was not working i think because
here
and then and there's an issue like the
knight would get
attacked and and if you play f6 that
would be rookie one
f6 maybe was an interesting choice it's
not like it wasn't good it was
it was a nice it was a nice oh here
you're right
actually good that you brought brought
it up this was another moment where
white could have had his
his really awesome idea here if you
remember i didn't mention that i almost
forgot
of reminding it this would have been a
really nice idea where girlfriend could
have
actually had big chances to win in this
moment
queen to b2 instead he traded the knight
he probably thought
he will have sufficient pressure he will
have sufficient pressure but actually he
did not have so this would have been the
right moment
for him to really go for it and have his
chance
of beating nepo
um a6 i don't know a5 was probably the
best
practical continuation and he's done it
i think he has
some good sense of that he's uh i think
he's an aggressive player it's certainly
going to be interesting i cannot tell
that much really we'll have to wait and
see
december is not that far away uh we'll
have to wait and see and they i think
they might be playing
more online stuff so uh it will be
interesting to
to to see what what comes with it
all right well i really do hope you
enjoyed this video
stay tuned for another one live stream
in about five minutes
see you guys very soon thanks for
watching don't forget to follow and
subscribe